hi youtube its grace sorry that the the
camera quality is exceptionally shitty
on this blog because I am for those of
you who don't know my iMac is broken and
is in the shop and so now I'm using my
laptop to film everything and it just
isn't very good I'm back again with
another story for you if you don't love
stories don't proceed with this video if
you do love stories this is gonna be a
great time so I was leaving Michelle's
place today because we did some awesome
filming that was awesome and we filmed
and I was walking back in it I decided
to go in a shop called Brooklyn
industries it is clothing and it's very
nice clothing it's expensive clothing I
usually don't buy the clothes but I like
looking at them because I like to
imagine myself wearing those clothes if
anyone out there from Brooklyn
industries let's say give me some free
clothes hey I'm not gonna not take them
I will take them so I like to look at
their sales right but even their sales
clothes are more expensive than I would
normally pay for clothes 50 dollars is
what a shirt cost that's on sale at
Brooklyn Industries I could buy 10 to $5
scratch off tickets with the potential
to win more money if clothes came with
some sort of puzzle element that allowed
you to potentially win more money I
think I would buy more clothes
great idea don't take it please I'm the
only one in the shop and so all the shop
people aka the employees are being very
nice to me and friendly and asking if I
need any help which I never need help in
the shop let me make this very clear to
anyone if you ever come across me and
you are a shop worker Justin you don't
have to help me I will find my way
around or I will panic that I can't find
something and I'll just leave
I'll just go it's not worth it at that
point for me I'm looking for the sales
rack and by myself and then another girl
comes in and for those of you who are
not of the female gender let me explain
the unwritten rules of shopping when
you're a girl you give each other space
you don't look at the same clothes until
the other person has moved away from
that space and you just give each other
space to shop this lady did not know the
unwritten rules of shopping she came
right over to me and hovered right next
to me she was just on me like white on
rice I don't know why that phrase is
that phrase and I thought this is weird
maybe this is someone I know playing a
joke on me and then I looked at her
unrecognizable to me I didn't know her
she was just all up in my grill cooking
meat on my shoulder I kept moving down
the sales rack and she kept moving with
me and then at one point I was touching
this shirt and looking at it and she
literally just stopped put her hands on
her hips and stared at me looking at
this shirt and just waited and she just
waited she wanted that shirt and so I
had a explosion of thoughts in my head
of is this woman crazy is she going to
kill me I think she wants this shirt
which kind of makes me want it because
girls are really competitive when
they're shopping 10 or 15 seconds I'm
perusing and this woman is just hands on
hips waiting for me to move in a store
that no one else is in the entire store
was open she didn't follow the rules and
so finally I like gladiator punching
with those giant q-tips that just can't
take anymore I just succumb to the
pressure and I jumped off the platform I
lost the battle I walked away and I
looked at the normal price stuff which I
wasn't even gonna buy I wasn't gonna buy
any of the sell stuff but I just wanted
to touch it but then it turned out that
the shirts weren't in her size says she
couldn't buy them anyway by YouTube
thanks for listening I'll see you next
time